renouvelée pour apporter de la jeunesse
au sein de la classe politique c'est le
message affiché par les jeunes avec
macron un mouvement dans marche un
discours séduisant pour plusieurs
étudiants yvelinois ce qui m'a convaincu
c'est la nouveauté et le fait qu'on
écoute vraiment les gens ont fait des
réunions où on parle tout le monde
s'écoute
il ya une vraie entente et les jeunes
comme les moins jeunes et de toutes les
catégories sociales on a notre place
dans le mouvement
à la fin ils libèrent l'économie tout en
protégeant les salariés avec le
l'allocation-chômage universel et pour
les indépendants les commerçants les
entrepreneurs et c'est une mesure du
programme d' emmanuel macron destiné aux
jeunes développer la formation en
alternance dans tous les lycées
professionnels
objectif favoriser l'insertion sur le
marché du travail
les jeunes sont ceux qui feront l'avenir
c'est ce qu'ils font les métiers de
l'avenir et on parle beaucoup de
transformations transformation numérique
transformation nos emplois intégration
dans la mondialisation et je pense que
les jeunes ont leur mot à dire sur ce
sujet il ya une volonté de faire de la
politique différemment cette politique
différemment c'est d'abord l'intégration
tous les citoyens le renouvellement
comporte c'est la parité utilisé leur
nation des partis politiques la probité
en fait partie également
et donc c'est effectivement une marque
de fabrique du mouvement marche
étudiante en sciences politiques
capucine a décidé de s'engager dans la
campagne en septembre dernier son rôle
gérer l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
le numérique est un outil stratégique
important pour emmanuel macron
la pause et nous à paris
l'action des gens le mouvement des
jeunes avec macron revendique près de
vingt mille adhérents en france